[Music]
just when we thought we'd seen it all at
the vmas in flies dosiacat
literally i'm here i'm here on sunday
night the pop star hosted the 2021 video
music awards and took a break from her
mc duties to give one epic performance
seemingly flying inside to her hit song
been like this
[Music]
dosia later came back down to earth
performing her song you right giving
mixed martial arts realness
[Music]
and on top of hosting and performing at
the event the singer also took home two
awards for best art direction for the
best friend video with sweetie
[Music]
and best collaboration alongside sizza
for their song kiss me more
accepting the award in this worm costume
she also presented in earlier in the
night
i look like a worm
that's dope
[Applause]
i never thought i'd be dressed as a worm
while accepting an award we had a
feeling dozia would be bringing her
fashion a game to the big night because
this is what she told et ahead of the
show so my stylist really wants me to
wear
2400 million thousand
billion trillion outfits
for one day because we're trying to hide
from the fbi and the government
it really feels like that sometimes like
when you change your outfit in your hair
every five minutes it feels like you're
running from the cops we're not
um i'm gonna try any aliases
three outfits maybe something like that
you know
she also dished to et about why she was
nervous about hosting the show i am like
a instagram live person i get on when
i'm at home i have nothing to do and i'm
comfy there but when it comes to like
the pressure of like this is the vmas
usually things turn out fine but i'm
pretty pessimistic let me just host it
from my bed
thank you with a with a wrestling helmet
on that'd be fine i'm okay with that